we were just talking about how Manfred
is handling baseball and all this stuff
if there's one sport that hadn't gone
woke and it was like hiding the corner
nobody but nobody was bothering it was
NHL and then we heard what happened this
week with the NHL yeah hey you guys are
not you know uh diverse enough and you
you saw this case here the NHL's first
internal demographic study found its
Workforce to be overwhelmingly white Kim
Davis NHL EVP of social impact uh uh
growth and legislative affairs has seen
the number is a first step towards
fixing a problem what are your thoughts
on this all right horseshit I mean it
listen this is why the country is where
it is when you're when your
qualifications and criteria to get a job
are based on your skin color and your
religion you're not picking the best
people well look at the vice president
of the United States there's not a
bigger box of rocks in existence than
this woman and and she is affirmative
action live she's never done anything
that you would look at and say well that
merits her being someone in a position
of prominence and Power in this country
because she clearly understands what's
going on she doesn't have a grasp of
anything and and and when you have I'll
never forget this I don't know if you if
you ever saw this but when Wikileaks
came out and all of the all of the
emails from the Clinton campaign were
revealed and I I mean I I read through
tons of them and there was a document
and podesta was on it but it was a
document listing a bunch of cabinet
positions and sub-cabinet positions and
they had the position and the candidates
listed were uh what we need we need a
black lit or a Latino we need a
homosexual in this one we need a a an
Asian man in this position and none of
them had anything to do with
qualifications of the position and
you're starting to see that permeate in
the real world people are getting hired
and and promoted and are doing things
based on any anything but their job
qualifications and that's what I my
argument for as a conservative has
always been I don't care what color you
are I don't care who you sleep with and
I don't care you pray to are you a
law-abiding legal American citizen of
any color race who can achieve at the
job I need you to achieve to if you go
back and look at Trump's four years and
you look at the fact that the Liberals
would like to tell you look he hired and
fired so many people well I I think a
lot of them having known Mr Trump
president Trump since 2006 he's a
pragmatist he's a problem solver right
and I think what he thought was a lot of
people in the private sector their
success was going to translate into
government and it didn't so when they
they came in and he saw that they
weren't doing the job he said okay
you're fired and he moved some and
everybody else saw that as instability
and and unstable and I saw that as I
need to find the right person for the
job man woman doesn't matter
and then you have other administrations
who hire and never fire anybody and that
tells me that we're living their
mistakes because not everybody's right
for the job meaning it was like a favor
when they hired somebody I owed you a
favor I hired you where Trump didn't
have a favor you helped get me elected I
promise you a position on the board
patient yeah here it is doesn't mean
you're the best person for the job but
go ahead I mean Pete bootage it
really that's your guy hey that guy
fixed potholes right in Indiana I mean
seriously you look at some of these
people and the challenges it's gotten so
ridiculous that we joke about it now did
you hear about the buildback better uh
the money that uh uh you know won the
most Biden calls it one of the most
incredible
um you know what do you want to call it
uh infrastructure bills history Mankind
and they it is incredible they just
spend the first they just spend the
first one they taught but it is they
just spend the first 20 million you know
what it is
did you did you see this thing the the
first 20 million that was spent to uh uh
the sidewalks of this city and they went
and interviewed this people in the city
they said you know you're getting the
first 20 million what are we doing with
that 20 million we're going to hit your
sidewalks so the ice can melt
the citizens that city is like what are
you talking about I get the wrong place
to spend the 20 million dollars on well
they're trying to block out the sun now
too have you seen that yes they have
plans they're they're trying to actually
block it out you know Sports on the
field is the ultimate meritocracy the
fans don't care
um back in 2004 Calgary Flames uh made
it to the finals and uh lost to Tampa
and it's when the entire NHL kind of
flipped out because the retirement
community had a Stanley Cup yeah and um
your own again love us on that team and
he was beloved you know you would see up
in Calgary it was up there he was
absolutely beloved he was an
African-American on the ice it was can
you skate can you shoot are you valuable
to the team and I think when you look at
the NHL Gary is the worst commissioner
in professional sports which is really
hard to do because there's a lot of
competition
okay the and you you sit back and say is
it a good thing to raise awareness so
that we make sure that everyone has an
opportunity for front office jobs and
everything yes it is but to the fans the
fans it's a meritocracy
the government spending thing one of the
things that that and I get I don't want
to say physically ill but it's it's
borderline I'll get acid reflux at the
at the discussion there's 32 000
homeless veterans in this country every
single night there should not be a
dollar of our government's money exiting
the borders of this country are being
spent for anything until they have a
roof over their heads and that just that
that I and I say that because you were
mentioning that that 20 million I just
saw something we're sending something
like uh 22 200 million 20 million to
South America to uh help uh transgender
activities in the community of South
America
Tran like like uh dancers and I mean the
stuff that we're seeing in the United
States with these kids being put in
front of transgender these these the the
the the the the cross-dressing dancers
and all the things that are going and
it's like
it doesn't seem real to me we're arguing
about things that to me are
they're not they're not there's no logic
to the argument but the left is winning
because we're having the argument to
begin with why are we arguing about who
can vote in our election how is that an
argument can I go to Germany and vote in
their election or Mexico no why are
people allowed to come here and vote
if they don't if they're not citizens
why is and then secondly why are we even
arguing it but that's the win right
we're discussing something we shouldn't
even be discussing
that's like me coming in your house and
telling you how you should paint the
wall in your living room it's and I
don't even live in here
but again why are we arguing things that
aren't just they're not even logical
yeah why are we arguing about what
bathroom a man or a woman should be able
to use how is that a logical argument so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]